manger sur le pouce et bien s'alimenter
est-ce que c'est vraiment réaliste le
journaliste Alain roi s'est penché sur
les menus des chaînes de restauration
rapide d'allure santé conclusion vous
allez probablement rester sur votre faim
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
de restauration rapide ont beaucoup
changé mecdonald's A&W ou Burger King
font face à une concurrence de la part
de chaîne qui joue la carte des repas
d'apparence saine
on a visité ces chaînes qui sont bien
implantées à Montréal et analyser leurs
différents menus qui c'est mon option de
tous les jours je viens de venir au
restaurant
comme ici à tous les jours mais je me
dis ah ben je vais prendre des bols
végétariens ou peu importe sandwich BG
avec des légumes je vais faire un bon
choix ça va être bon pour ma santé
attention peut-être pas ce midi là on a
voulu comparer certains de ses repas à
des choix de restauration rapide
traditionnelle un trio A&W un sandwich
et un bol repas chez culture
[Musique]
relativement similaire aux fast-food
bien connue à W et compagnie parce que
c'est possiblement riche en gras
possiblement riche en sel il y a des
choix qui sont quand même meilleurs moi
je trouve que leur gros avantage par
rapport au sein de fascaux régulières
c'est la présence de légumes c'est une
bonne moyenne c'est pas là par rapport
au ballon d'ici qu'on a trouvé on a
suffisamment protéines donc ça c'est
intéressant parce que on pourrait penser
à certains choix alimentaires des fois
qui sont faible en protéines 10 12 g et
là ça va pas me rassasier suffisamment
donc ici on a 25 g de protéines c'est ce
qui est très bien en devin 30 g de côté
c'est ce qu'on veut pour un repas qui va
vraiment avoir un effet de facilité
intuitivement les choix végétariens
semblent toujours plus santé dans la
tête de beaucoup de gens BG
= santé mais je peux très bien manger
quelque chose de baiser qui est
transformé riche en riche en gras et
sans sucre concentré donc c'est pas une
association qui devrait se faire
automatiquement
donc on a des tranches de champignons
shiitake qui est mélangé avec une base
de protéines de soya donc ça c'est
végétarien vegan et on a aussi beaucoup
de tofu mariné
on vend surtout des salades la base
beaucoup de verdure
mais on a aussi des offres avec du
poulet du poisson donc on n'est pas si
strictement vegan ou végétariennes on a
quelque chose pour tout le monde ici
depuis 2007 au Canada la loi oblige
l'industrie alimentaire afficher les
valeurs nutritives sur l'étiquette des
aliments pré-emballés ce n'est pas le
cas des repas achetés sur le pouce aux
États-Unis c'est beaucoup plus flagrant
on voit les calories sont le menu c'est
beaucoup plus présents
pendant les chercher sur internet si on
veut les avoir vous avez pas de valeur
détritives
je pense que oui
pour une comparaison simple un trio chez
A&W compte 900 calories alors que juste
le bol californien de culture en compte
770 les calories me donnent une idée du
contenant mais pas du contenu je peux
avoir un même nombre de calories deux
plats avec un qui est très nutritif et
un autre qui est plus riche en sel en
gras et moins de moins d'éléments
intéressants au niveau de la santé
[Musique]
avec Eve on a épluché quelques menus qui
ont une race hantée
[Musique]
comme ça mais ça reste quand même plus
intéressant qu'un burger
[Musique]
les fameux burritos sont très populaires
très bons très costaud mais très riche
en glucides si on la plupart des
végétaux ont plus de 100 g de glucides
avec le tortillas le riz à l'intérieur
c'est beaucoup pour un repas pour
quelqu'un qui dépense pas beaucoup
d'énergie
si on voit qu'ils ont mis la sauce
directement sur le plat on aurait très
bien pu demander avant la sauce à part
normalement il accepte de le faire et ça
ça me permet moi de contrôler un peu
plus la sauce que je vais mettre
possiblement que ça me ferait réduire le
total de gras dans mon assiette ça forme
très équilibrée très santé parfois il
est quand même mais 950 mg de sodium
dans cette beurre sachant que on
recommande de manger à peu près 1500 mg
de sodium dans une journée c'est
quasiment la totalité de ce que
j'aimerais manger en un bol
au moins dit possiblement un repas qui
est moins équilibré le risque que je
vois chez ma vie c'est que pas tout le
temps c'est pas comme un bol où est-ce
qu'on a souvent le riz quinoa tout ça il
peut manquer de glucides donc ça peut
faire en sorte que oui j'ai plein de
légumes intéressants mais j'en ai
toujours besoin d'un minimum de glucides
également pour être assassiné dans notre
menu si vous voulez prendre on a des
chips on a du bacon on a beaucoup de
fromages donc on peut se créer même
comme un Big Mac de salade mais c'est
pas nécessairement ça qu'on veut vendre
que qui nous représente
[Musique]
aussi il y a une aura santé
pour avoir mon 20 à 30 g de protéines
le fameux burger aux champignons porte
de l'eau attention ça se peut que ce
soit pas suffisamment rassasié
mais il y a des protéines végétales
comme le tofu le tempe
des légumineuses vont souvent être
beaucoup plus constante et riche en
protéines
[Musique]
oui c'est végétarien mais comme c'est
Free c'est gras j'ai fait intéressant
pour la panthère verte j'ai marqué qu'il
y avait aussi
mais non menu beaucoup de notions avec
le fruit du Jacquet si j'en passe dans
mon port il fait lâché par les fous de
Jacquie même si ça goûte simplement la
même chose et beaucoup moins protides
c'est pas parfait
[Musique]